cause I'm good I'm feeling all right
baby
[Music]
if it was not stuck in your head already
it is now that was Bebe Rex's viral hit
I'm good blue and joining us now is BB
herself Hi how are you you're pink not
blue I'm very pink I tried doing blue
but I ended up with pink today somehow
you look beautiful as usual and thank
you so much for hanging out with us
congratulations on this track to say it
is a monster I feel like is an
understatement and this series of events
behind I'm good are wild and Cosmic and
I feel like I gotta hear it from you
basically how it all went down because
it started with someone leaking a bit of
the song on Tick Tock correct well first
of all it's a really crazy story so
crazy I happen to be in London at the
same time that David Guetta was in
London we were both writing and he was
like I you know I texted him I said
ghetto what are you doing he's like I'm
in London writing and I said me too I
said let's write together so we go into
the studio and he plays me this remix of
the Eiffel 65 song Blue and I go let's
write to this for fun let's just let's
just write to it and see what happens
you know so we write the song we think
nothing of it a week later he plays it
at a festival
somebody takes a video of it post it on
YouTube Somebody takes that video from
YouTube posted on Tick Tock it makes a
remix of it and it goes absolutely viral
[Music]
so I sent it to my team and they go I go
look at this and they go Bibi that's you
and I go wait what do you mean that's me
I said this song Never we never even
released a song and
I find out the song is viral on Tick
Tock and my voice is all over I'm like
what is going on and you guys wrote that
song what five years ago so the five
years ago it's been five years since we
wrote the song oh my goodness yeah and
now like again like I said a monster I
think people right now are they want
that Nostalgia they they want the 2000s
are back you know it's like we want to
be back in that world and I think
everybody wants to be happy I think
that's what this song is all about it's
about feeling all right and just going
out and having the time of your life
[Music]
never in my life would I believe you if
you told me that I would write the
anti-version of blue because blue is
about being sad and I would write the
same song Take the same Melody but write
it and make it happy and that it would
still be a worldwide hit wild the way
life works out and then you guys have
this Killer music video you're like the
ultimate mood in this video thank you
going into it what was the vision that
you wanted to bring to it I mean it was
it's you know as an as a Virgo I guess
I'm never fully happy with what I do we
had such a short turnaround for the
video because we by the time we found
out that it was going viral we were like
oh we need we gotta jump on it we need
to release we need to shoot a music
video in a totally different country and
mix the song and finish writing it and
record it in under a week and I'm like
we have a week how are we gonna do all
this you know so it was kind of rushed
you know but we had a good time it was
I've never been to a b I had such an
amazing time there I had some delicious
food it's absolutely gorgeous there and
I love like two just the full circle
relationship with David you guys go
years back and now you are sharing this
track together and it all started and
with a day in London literally a day a
day in London and
um
it's it just happens so many times in my
career it's crazy even like with meant
to be with Florida Georgia Line it was
the same situation of a last minute
music session it is meant to be
Let It Be good luck yeah the magic of
that song yeah you've I've followed you
for years now on social media and one
thing that I've always admired about you
is how honest you are with your fans of
the difficulties
being an artist in this business that is
very very very tough to be in do you
feel
how does this win this number one this
massive song how does that make you feel
right now
um I honestly have learned to I've been
trying to be in my own little I I've
been trying to find happiness in other
ways like through my family through my
friends through food all right yeah here
I am um
celebrating the success of you know
I I just I feel like when you do things
out of love and passion like I truly
love writing songs and I truly love
collaborating and working on music and
I'm so grateful because I know how it
feels to have an up and then I know how
it feels to have it down and I love how
you inspire people to be totally
unbothered to buy them because I love
seeing people win and I it's like you
know unless you're like in a really
tough place in your life and you don't
like seeing but I like seeing people win
but it's so much better when somebody
fails and then wins then that's like
that's really cool we'll get to the top
by being ourselves and not catering to
the mold so you inspire other people
like that you never know listen I for a
very for you know when I have put out my
album you know it was like with covid
and everything and I sat on it for like
three years and it was really it was
really hard because you put so much love
you know like you never want to put a
project out and not have it succeed or
do anything but I think it was such a
for my last project it was such a weird
timing and with covid and and just
sitting on things that you never want to
see anything that you do not do great
you know and then you get into you you
get into really I got into a really dark
head space you know because you're like
damn like what did I what could I have
done better what could I have and
you just gotta in life you just gotta
pick yourself back up
what is next for you on the heels of
this momentum what is next
I have another collaboration coming out
which I'm very excited about it's with a
very big Latin star
male or female male okay he's absolutely
incredible and it's with another DJ and
um the song is the meaning of the song
is so amazing and it's such a feel-good
dance record that I'm so so I haven't
been this excited for a song to come out
like properly
um so I'm really excited about that and
then 2023 we have new Bebe rexha what is
the vibe of that new project I think
with this next project I really sat down
and said I want to make an artistic
project that really speaks to my soul
because I'm a grown woman now I'm no I'm
you know I'm 33 years old and I have a
lot to say and I'm in a relationship
I've there's just so many things that
I'm learning about life and I was like I
want to put this into a project but I
want it to be artistic and I want it to
be well thought out so I've been working
on a project very closely for the last
year and I'm really excited for the
world to hear it I'm so excited to hear
because as someone from the outside like
you just seem like you are at such a
high energy vibration personally and
professionally Bibi thank you so much
for hanging out with us and y'all
Phoebe's viral hit I'm good is out now
Bibi thank you so much for joining us
y'all we're gonna let Bibi play us out
with the viral hit I'm good
[Music]
[Applause]